you thought ukraine should be part of
europe absolutely 100 percent and in
fact my whole time there and this is all
but the client didn't want that though
no that's not true that's not true in
fact if you look at his
his presidency
uh you will see that the ch
the changes that were made in ukraine
yeah uh over those three and a half
years of his presidency we changed the
economic system the legal system and the
uh
the regulatory system working with the
european union directly and i was
working with european union directly
again are you talking about yanukovych
yeah i'm talking about yeah which and
this this has been part of the 1314
he was elected president in 2010 right
and immediately the first thing he did
was go to brussels and commit himself to
working with brussels to become part of
ukraine
when historically all previous new
incoming presidents went to moscow first
uh it was very controversial very
controversial not going to moscow he
understood what he was doing he
understood the symbolism of it and so
did the europeans and so did the
americans and they started working with
him
and and
the
if you look at and this is all public
information but it's not convenient
facts
if you look at what he did during those
three and a half years he prepared
ukraine to become part of europe he even
said that while he wasn't committed to
make ukraine part of nato yet because
that was too controversial of a decision
inside inside ukraine he left that
question open
and it was only when
uh putin realized that the negotiations
for the trade agreement which was the
predecessor for the associate the
political association agreement was
about to be signed
that putin's threatened yanukovych
publicly again this is all public
information
and said to said the anticoage that if
you sign this trade agreement i will
immediately shut down all trade with
ukraine which was approximately 70
percent of ukraine's trade and the trade
agreement that we had negotiated with uh
said that publicly oh yeah
and threat because the decision was made
sudden there's celebration everyone's
outside kids are waiting
college students are waiting they're
about to go out there and party hard you
know the scene you've seen it and all of
a sudden boom well we're not going to do
it but but there's a lot more to the
story and that that's all again public
information
uh yeah when when putin made that threat
publicly because because he wanted
ukraine to be part of a trade
association that he was creating he
putin
unicorn said no
um and you know covert said
we actually asked uh beaudrock the
president of the european union uh for
a a subsidy to help ukraine bridge
the time frame when it was become going
to sign the association agreement
because the way this document read if
you look at it
the the all the advantages in the first
three to four years were favorable to
european companies because ukraine was
basically taking down its barriers and
its trade uh its trade barriers and its
in its own uh tariffs uh in in allowing
it to be a free trade part of the free
trade association
and if
russia was going to shut 70 percent of
their trade down
of the country now
all of us trade with with ukraine but
seventy percent of the of the foreign
trade
ukraine couldn't have survived that
and so it needed the subsidy the
european said no
uh and yanukovych then said look i can't
sign this and have my country shut down
if you're not willing to help me but i'm
not
saying i'm not going to sign it i've got
to work out this problem because two you
know a week before or whatever it was
when he made this final statement
ukraine ukraine learned that it was
going to have its markets shut down
that's when everything fell apart
that's when everything exploded did he
did he share that with his people this
is this is public information
but what i'm trying to say is in that
moment when he said i can't
did he share that with his people that
70 of our commerce that goes through
russia we're going to lose
this was all publicly yes absolutely 100
that that same debt that's that's in you
go back and you look uh at the
international news you look at what
putin threatened you look at the
ukrainian news of the impact of what
that would be you look at what was being
said to the uh to the european uh union
members
it was this is all public information so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]